a Starbucks employee has gone viral
For Whining in the back room about how
tough the job is
people wonder why we need a union at
Starbucks and I
am literally about to quit like I I
don't know if I'm gonna do it but like I
really want to I almost walked out today
and I'm crying in the back room right
now and I must cut on the floor it's
just
I like it gets I'm like a full-time
student I get scheduled for 25 hours a
week and then on weekends they scheduled
me the entire day open to close out on
the schedule for eight and a half hours
both Saturday and Sunday I'm like three
and a half hours into my shift there's
so many customers and we have four
people on the floor all day
and then people are yelling at me
because I don't have their orders ready
because I don't know what to do
it and the customer was misgendering me
today like really badly I didn't have
their order ready and so they were just
like totally talking like tender and
they're like she's clearly incompetent I
have a full mustache and beard
no
I don't get accommodations for being
neurodivergent I only got my Woods out
with this job
ever since he brought up the issue of
misgendering I actually don't know I
don't know what gender he is so I'll use
he which is the gender neutral singular
pronoun
he's very upset because he has to work
sometimes 25 hours a week
sometimes he has to work a full shift
a full shift being
eight and a half hours
how many how many people
only work eight hours a day
even maybe you work eight hours a day at
your job but then
I know very few people who can get by
working just eight hours a day or even
who want to only work eight hours a day
I'm being told by the way by the
producers that the the video is of a of
a woman who I guess is taking hormones
and it's very it was a little tough to
tell because the the it's so zoomed in
tight on her face that you can't quite
get a picture of the whole body and
height and everything to see uh what sex
she is so she's obviously
a troubled person she's obviously got a
severe mental illness she probably
should be in a therapist's office rather
than trying even to work a job she's
obviously not capable of working a job
but it actually raises a lesson for all
of us in society
not not just the ones who are kind of
crazy and think we're the opposite sex
and the you know spoiled snowflake young
people who you know never had to work a
tough job in their life or whatever for
all of us we have a lesson here
this woman should be very thankful to
Starbucks
for presenting her with hardship and
giving her an opportunity to mature
and giving her an opportunity to do a
difficult thing working at Starbucks
actually is a difficult job you gotta
I've worked I've worked in fast food
I've worked at restaurants I've worked
plenty of service jobs it can be very
tough it's very demanding customers can
be tough you got to do things a mile a
minute especially at the lunch rush or
the afternoon Coffee Rush so yeah I'm
sure it's a tough job and the main thing
the main takeaway that this young lady
should find in this year is
to stop complaining
stop complaining it is it is such a gift
and and for everybody in life to face
hardship and then not complain
and suffer in silence and cultivate a
spirit of resignation and patience and
fortitude all of which are virtues that
are completely forgotten in our I'm
getting so angry I'm gonna throw my
microphone off here that are completely
forgotten in our decadent modern culture
it's really it's wonderful that will
that will make you a stronger person it
will make you a better person it'll make
you a Holier person if you do that
you don't need to whine about every
problem in fact you should never whine
ever about anything
you can engage in criticism especially
if that criticism can be effective I
mean that's what the show is right we're
criticizing the modern culture but not
we're not criticizing it from the
perspective of things are so bad right
now I hate it isn't this a terrible
world no quite the opposite we're saying
this is what's bad here's how we got to
fix it this is what we got to stop doing
this is what we got to start doing here
is this is this is not working as well
as it should right now here's a better
policy to put in its place that's that's
a wonderful thing fixing things is a
wonderful thing
but but whining and complaining and
saying woe is me you should never say
that excise that from your vocabulary
because we all make fun of that chick at
Starbucks
we are all we have all been that chick
at some point in our lives
we have especially me because I can't
really grow a beard that well so you
know it's pretty patchy actually not so
different you know especially today that
I'm in my Rachel Maddow costume for
Halloween
we
have all been that chick at some point
and then I hope most of us have grown up
and learn to not we're living in a time
when we're told don't repress anything
don't know you've got to let it all out
you've just got to talk don't talk about
your feelings when when you complain
when you whine you put burden on other
people
you there's a study about this there was
a study it just came out I just saw this
in the Drudge Report so you know take it
with a grain of salt but it's citing
real academics here
that stress spreads like a virus from
people to people
the neuroscientist Tom Tony W Buchanan
who's a professor at St Louis University
measured the response of people who were
simply observing stress in others and he
found that the observer's cortisol
levels spiked via a phenomenon known as
stress contagion the spread of stress
from person to person like a virus and
we all know anecdotally that this is
true
we all know that this is true
because we if you've ever had a sort of
difficult relative or you know a friend
who's just constantly whining about
everything you know it puts you on edge
as well and I wonder too as I say the
chief cause of all of our ills in the
modern age is not some political
philosopher or some government
bureaucrat or some stupid policy or
something it's that people are not
getting baptized and so demons are
running amok because we don't have
enough exorcisms going on it's just a
fact okay we say hard facts on this show
that's one of them but another cause of
so much of the disorder I wonder if it's
because we have these social media feeds
feeds right we're just constantly
feeding ourselves like horses with a
slot bag on except we're feeding
ourselves images and and uh audio and
and videos and things like that and so
much of that content
is really angry stressful content where
it's you know the transgender person
yelling and screaming and you know it's
the even people on the right often do
this I sometimes fear that I will I will
never have a career in political
commentary I guess I do have one but in
the long run because I can't get angry
I get angry like twice a year and most
political commentary is someone sort of
just shaking their fist at the screen or
yelling into a microphone I just can't
do that I'm not that angry I'm dismayed
at the state of the world I would like
to turn things around I got some ideas
on how to do that but I just because
it's just it's just rude to be angry and
whining and complaining all the time and
it shows that you're not in control of
your emotions and it shows that you
haven't cultivated a higher will and it
shows that you're still given to your
base passions don't do it don't be like
that chick at Starbucks folks let me
yell that into the microphone don't be
like that chicken Starbucks because it
will make you very unhappy and it will
make the people around you very unhappy
as well today is music Monday baby and
so my producers assure me they've got a
wonderful song for me to listen to to
analyze because I am a hip-hop Maven the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
foreign
[Music]
[Music]